[Music]
we showed you earlier that the u.s just
hit a new record for daily covet cases
this morning europe is also in crisis
britain reported almost 130 000 new
cases yesterday its highest daily number
since the pandemic began germany france
and spain are also breaking records that
means new restrictions with each country
taking a different approach as charlie
daggetto reports
the streets of paris would normally be
packed over the festive period but not
after france reported a record high
nearly 180 thousand cases in a single
day people have been asked to work from
home three days a week and new year's
eve celebrations have been called off
too
sure a lot of people will be
disappointed the fireworks are canceled
he says especially in paris but we have
to stop this contagion
they're not alone italy greece portugal
and england all reported record one-day
highs
although early studies suggest omicron
may be causing milder illness than
previous variants reading university's
dr simon clark warned omicron should not
be underestimated uh we are in a
situation where we don't know with any
surety at all how many people are going
to end up in hospital so while we don't
know that we cannot design those
restrictions to to bring down the number
of infections by the level that is
needed
new stiffer lockdowns across europe
includes shutting nightclubs and
cancelling large-scale events germany
has banned groups of more than 10 from
gathering in order to discourage new
year's eve parties yet england decided
not to impose any further restrictions
instead pushing for people to get
vaccinations and boosters it's a
confusing picture if they get this right
and and don't lock down or don't impose
further restrictions when they don't
need to they will be hailed for that but
if they get it wrong there will be
serious political trouble if they end up
filling the hospitals with people
struggling to breathe and this is the
same situation we may be looking at in
the united states
exactly it's the same situation any
government is looking at
the world health organization has issued
a new warning that omicron could
overwhelm global health systems here in
the uk prime minister boris johnson says
the vast majority of patients in
intensive care have not had booster
shots vlad
all right charlie daggett in london for
us charlie thank you as always my friend